we need heroes we need you  Captain Marvel is about somebody who  goes on a journey of discovery and I  think it was really important for breed  to learn ahead of sight by the time we  started shooting I had been training for  nine months  and I'm glad that I did doing my  sequence is up and down and trained for  three days well kind of alive the thing  that I found so unique about this  character was that sense of humor mixed  with total capability and whatever  challenge comes her way you know how to  fly this thing you see which I realized  after going to Air Force Base is really  what Air Force pilots are like that's a  yes or no question yes  and we simulated a dogfight we were on  offense we were on the defense we got to  6.5 G's amazing it's a lot a lot of work  she brings so much of that to the role  it's pretty awesome  [Music]